mais avec nous pour en parler
pierre rochefort tellier infirmiers
l'hôpital beaujon à paris vous êtes
membre du collectif inter urgence
laurent alexandre essayiste et
chirurgiens enfin didier maïsto
journaliste indépendant bonsoir à tous
les toits messieurs merci d'être en
direct avec nos sur rt france l'appel
aux français on est plus rester chez
vous qu'on a beaucoup entendu mais
vaccinez vous olivier verront donc y
lancent un ultimatum aux retardataires
et réfractaires à la vaccination en
filigramme la menace que la vaccination
ne devienne obligatoire laurent
alexandre c'est cela qui nous pend au
nez
écoutez moi je suis plutôt optimiste on
observe que dans les sondages le
pourcentage de français qui souhaitent
se faire vacciner est passé de 41 % à
plus de 80 % entre janvier et juin
ça veut dire que chaque semaine 1 5% des
français qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner en plus donc on a eu un
doublement des gens qui veulent être
vaccinés contre locaux vides de 19 ans
en six mois
je pense que ce taux va encore augmenter
notamment du fait que les vaccins arn
messager comme le modern and up there
qui sont majoritaires ont très largement
majoritaires ont extrêmement peu
d'effets secondaires
donc je pense que les craintes légitimes
qui ont eu les gens contre le hac sein
sont en train de de s'effacer
progressivement et donc je pense qu'il
faut pousser les gens à se faire
vacciner mais je suis contre la
vaccination obligatoire contre
l'ensemble de la population en revanche
bien évidemment pour nous les soignants
pour l'ensemble des gens en contact avec
les malades la vaccination obligatoire
et nécessaire
le but des soignants c'est de sauver des
malades c'est de sauver des vies ce
n'est pas de les contaminer et de les
tuer quand ils sont fragiles
donc il est absolument indispensable de
de rendre la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous les gens qui soigne il serait
criminel il serait totalement anti
déontologique anti éthique de toucher un
malade de soigner un malade sans être
vaccinés c'est inacceptable
hier enfin tellier qu'est ce que vous
répondez criminels antilles
déontologique de toucher à un malade
quand on n'est pas vacciné votre réponse
alors tout d'abord le collectif intel
relance n'est absolument pas contre le
vaccin nous appelons bien évidemment le
plus largement possible à se faire
vacciner mais nous sommes contre une
obligation parce que nous pensons qu'il
faut mieux convaincre que contraindre et
que contraindre une vaccination pour
avoir des conséquences très lourdes sur
le sort des soirs des futurs plans de
campagne de vaccination on a des
antécédents au niveau de l'hôpital
public au niveau des personnels sur les
vaccins de l'hépatite b ça a été fait
dans les années 70 on en parle encore
aujourd'hui 2 jusqu'en 2020 on vous a
encore des recherches pour voir s'il ya
des complications donc ça a laissé des
traces et je pense que forcer les gens
ça ne fait que renforcer les craintes
envers la vaccination et ça pourrait
être préjudiciable pour l'avenir et sur
les futures campagnes de vaccination
notamment sur la grippe
on a tous les ans et je pense qu'à
l'heure actuelle on a un travail qui est
en train d'être fait qu'ils évoluent les
les soignants sont quand même parler de
ceux qui sont les plus de matinée de la
population on a des chiffres qu'ils
veulent un peu rien dire puisque la thp
nous dit qu'on est vacciné 70% mais elle
n'a que les données sur ces sur des
professeurs qui sont vaccinées sur des
sites de l'ap hp n'ont absolument pas
les données des professionnels vacciner
à l'extérieur décide de l'ap-hp on a
d'autres données qui sont donnés par les
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie
qui donne à 91% puisqu'on met
directement sur une caisse différente de
la population classique et donc là les
chiffres sont peut être un petit peu
surélevé puisqu'il n'y a pas que des
soignants dedans mais on voit bien que
en tout cas on ne sait pas combien de
soignants ne sont pas vaccinés à l'heure
actuelle c'est un petit peu un écran de
fumée
puisqu'en réalité même si tous les
soignants sont vaccinés s'il doit y
avoir une quatrième vague il y aura une
quatrième vague
la réalité c'est qu'est ce que l'état
fait pour lutter contre cette pandémie
et l'état ne fait absolument rien
d'ailleurs l'état a comme consigne de
vivre avec cette épidémie est de ne pas
lutter contre ça si on voulait vraiment
lutter contre cette épidémie mais cette
semaine cette embellie
la première chose à faire ça aurait été
de lever les bras les brevets contre
c'est la chaussée lac st la plupart des
variantes nous observons aujourd'hui
viennent de pays qui n'ont pas accès à
des vaccins
donc tant qu'on laissera ces pays sans
vaccin on aura d'autres d'argent qui
arriveront donc je je suis un petit peu
aussi fatigué de cette stigmatisation
qui est fait sur des soignants de la
part notamment du ministre de la santé
qu'il ya 18 mois de disait que les tests
ne servent à rien que
ce que ne servent à rien et que c'était
une grippe c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué rth ait accepté le fait que
nous sommes responsables et criminel
aujourd'hui nous sommes vecteur de la
pathologie quand l'état aujourd'hui le
gouvernement choisisse de continuer à
fermer des lits on peut tous être
vaccinés s il ya publici la butte
soignant à l'hôpital il va pas pouvoir
faire grand chose et ne serait ce que
sur les pathologies autre que le coc
vide à l'heure actuelle l'hôpital son
urgence c'est de trouver des soignants
on en n'est pas vacciné les soignants
qu'il arrive on en est à trouver des
soignants ne serait ce que pour faire
fonctionner l'hôpital un didier maïsto
quand vous entendez pierre un choc
tellier dire voilà on en a marre non
soignants d'être stigmatisé l'état ne
fait finalement pas assez pour lutter
contre cette pandémie qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ce ce diagnostic
oui je pense d'abord que la vaccination
est un acte individuel personnel
quasiment intime contraindre dans le
pays des lumières et de pasteurs puisque
c'est ce qu'on nous sert souvent les
gens à se vacciner c'est le pire moyen
d'arriver à une vaccination
premièrement deuxièmement les français
ne sont pas idiots
ce sont des gens qui disent qu'ils se
documente qui regarde toutes les études
et je parle pas des complotistes et
autres bizarreries qu'on peut trouver
parce que je sais que le débat souvent
se focalise pour déprécier un petit peu
les doutes fondamentaux qui sont mis en
avant comme l'a dit pierre schwab
effectivement c'était et même le docteur
alexandre c'est bien légitime que les
gens doutent cette pandémie nous est
tombé dessus et les vaccins ont été très
vite fait on nous a dit 95 %
d'efficacité puis aujourd'hui on voit
bien que ce n'est pas le cas il ya
toujours un variant on est toujours en
retard d'un variant le principe d'un
virus c'est d'avoir des variants et donc
on sera toujours en retard d'un variant
troisième point puisque le docteur
alexandre en parler ce fameux sondage
cet enfant un sondage 81 % des gens les
citoyens français qui serait favorable à
la vaccination obligatoire se tombe à ce
sondage est un sondage au doxa pour le
figaro et france info qui est une
honteuse manipulation puisque c'est un
échantillon a panel de 1005 personnes
attendaient je vous ai pas interrompu je
vais je vais je vais aller au bout rond
nous entendîmes élections qu'est ce que
vous voulez voilà donc 1005 personnes
qui ont été sélectionnés dans ce panel
en réalité j'invite tout le monde à le
regarder puisque le sondage est publique
il est sur le site de doxa 25%
simplement des français est très été
très favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire 33%
je cite les chiffres de mémoire mais je
ne pense pas me tromper été assez
favorable qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui assez peut-être oui assez favorable
et ce sondage en plus inclut les
personnes qui étaient déjà vaccinés pour
arriver au chiffre mirifique de 80% ça
ça s'appelle en fait de la manipulation
mentale c'est du nuage
c'est du soft power n'est ce pas en
influence les gens et on pense que ça
vient d'eux et on a en un style dans le
débat public
cette finalement faculté d'adhérer à une
espèce d'intérêt général pourquoi les
gens se font vacciner aujourd'hui non
pas par un altruisme exacerbée je vais
être un peu cassant peut-être mais parce
qu'ils veulent partir en vacances
prendre des avions d aller au restaurant
ces sales histoires du passé ni sert il
pas sanitaire ce n'est pas du tout des
questions de santé publique ce ne sont
pas du tout les questions santé publique
et moi je trouve ça assez chaud comment
parce que je vois que depuis quatre ans
les libertés individuelles et
collectives se se se réduisent comme
peau de chagrin
on va laisser la réponse à laurent
alexandre qui voulait réagir alors allez
fais pas du tout du d'un sondage sur les
gens qui souhaitaient la vaccination
obligatoire je parlais du dd sondage
mensuel sur le pourcentage de français
qui souhaitent à titre personnel se
faire vacciner
donc je ne parlais pas du du sondage
doxa dans mesto parlait il faut bien
voir qu'en matière de vaccins c'est pas
un choix individuel si on à éradiquer la
variole qui est une menace beaucoup plus
grave que le coc vie r c'est parce que
la vaccination contre la variole a été
généralisé était obligatoire dans tous
les pays du monde
donc la vaccination il ya une dimension
individuelle se protéger meyer dimanche
on collective protéger les autres et
donc en réalité ce n'est pas uniquement
un acte individuel c'est aussi un acte
collectif
altruiste en me vaccine ans je protège
les autres et je le répète on est en
train d'éradiquer sur la surface de la
planète la poliomyélite comme on à
éradiquer la variole il ya 40 ans et ça
c'est ça la fait connaître comme
obligatoire dans la plupart des pays du
monde
un choix individuel ne permet pas d
indiquer une maladie par la vaccination
avant de vous redonner la parole pierre
chef d'atelier je voudrais vous faire
écouter gabriel atteint qui est parti
évidemment les aussi en croisade en
faveur de la vaccination collective
écouter mais le vario n'attendra pas et
il nous faut dès aujourd'hui mais couper
l'herbe sous le pied et ne le vaccin je
le répète est la carte maîtresse pour
cela l'heure est à la mobilisation
générale à la vaccination massive
que ce soit en se faisant vacciner ou en
convainquant un proche de se faire
vacciner chacun détient une part de la
solution chacun peut prendre part à
l'épreuve d'immunité collective qui nous
attend cet été voilà gabriela talent
olivier vers en a rajouté une couche ce
soir ils font nous faut aller plus vite
dans la vaccination des adultes plus
loin clairement pierre choc tellier on
sent une pression qui s'accentue
vous en tant que soignant on a compris
votre position vous êtes contre la
vaccination obligatoire mais ce que vous
allez vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce
côté on va s'atteler à convaincre les
réfractaires vous allez dans ce rôle là
vous par exemple notre c'est notre
mission et c'est notre travail de
convaincre d'aller chercher à avoir le
consentement libre et éclairé
ça ça a toujours été la mission des
protocoles de songer en attendant après
deux collègues ils sont libres et
éclairés et très clairement je vous le
dis sincèrement je ne connais que très
clairement je pense que je dois avoir
moins de 20 de la main de collègues qui
sont pas vaccinés sur tous les collègues
que je dois koné fait certainement pas
dans la plupart des collègues des
services d'urgence ou de réanimation
sont vaccinés à 100%
clairement oui vous vous sentez
justement pas pardonné mois à pierre
achoppent tellier
c'est vrai que voilà j'ai écouté un
petit peu les radios ce matin les débats
on sent une forme ça commence ce débat
un petit peu houleux entre les vacciner
les non-vaccinés presse une forme de
culpabilisation est ce que vous vous la
ressentez vous aussi à votre votre
niveau de ne pas en être enfin je parle
pas vous parce que je crois je crois
savoir vous êtes dac cinéma mais est-ce
qu'il ya sept ans on cherche à
culpabiliser maintenant ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas se faire vacciner est ce
que la pression va remplir et ces
prochains temps selon vous alors comme
vous lie à l'hôpital à l'heure actuelle
notre pression elle est surtout pour
trouver du personnel très clairement on
en est pas à discuter de la vaccination
au sein de l'hôpital est l'urgence
actuelle c'est d'essayer de maintenir
les lieux où air si vous voulez à
l'heure actuelle le gouvernement à
continuer à fermer 2008 100 lits nous
avons sur l ap-hp là où nous avions 400
lits de cerner sur la pêche vers 2019 on
en a 800 lits fermés pendant de
professionnels font en effet lire on est
dans une situation où déjà là à l'heure
actuelle on n'a pas de baco vide à
l'heure actuelle ou à l'hôpital on est
déjà débordé une hypothèse de relance
l'état ne garantit pas déjà les soins de
base
enfin je veux dire c'est non ça fait
trois ans qu'on se bat ça fait depuis
2000 19 qu'on se bat pour avoir du
matériel du personnel et délits après
une crise comme ça on voit que l'état
continue à sa politique de fermetures de
lits de restriction donc forcément qu'il
va falloir serrer les boulons pour sur
le personnel
mais on ne s'en sortira clairement pas
et même si le kobe de passe vers la
crise hospitalière elle sa sainte elles
s'accentuaient s'aggrave et en salle le
gouvernement ne répond absolument pas
alors là que dit il un autre information
de la journée à la cnil qui avait l'idée
aujourd'hui l'envoi au médecin traitant
de
liste de leurs patients non vaccinés par
l'assurance maladie ça veut dire quoi
clairement on va aller chercher les gens
un par un pour les faire changer d'avis
laurent alexandre vous êtes d'accord
avec cette mesure
elle est nécessaire les médecins doivent
savoir lesquels de leurs patients sont
vaccinés ne sont pas vaccinés c'est une
nouveau du médecin qu'on a le plus de
prises notamment sur les personnes les
plus fragiles les personnes âgées qui
vont régulièrement voir leur médecin
généraliste notamment
et donc il est je trouve justifiée de
permettre aux médecins de voir parmi
leurs patients quels sont les très
fragile qui ne sont pas vaccinés
il ne faut pas oublier que chez les
personnes âgées on a un taux de
mortalité due qu'aux vite qui est
extrêmement fort chez les gens de plus
de 80 ans ces 180 fois plus élevé que
chez les gens plus jeunes et donc il est
normal que l'on permette aux au médecin
d'avoir un outil pour piloter la
vaccination des gens fragiles qui risque
d'avoir un accident grave voire de
mourir si la quatrième vague liés aux
variants delta se développe dans les
semaines qui viennent a dit d'aimer sur
vous très attaché toujours en liberté
individuelle ça vous a choqué justement
colette nil valide cet envoi par
l'assurance maladie des non vacciné
leurs médecins traitants vont au
contraire vous pensez que c'est ces
médecins qui sont proches des gens ont
vraiment un rôle à jouer
ça m'a choqué bien sûr mais ça ma
passion puis comme toutes les autorités
administratives indépendantes
la cnil n'est pas indépendante je
pensais que moins en france il y avait
encore le secret médical le docteur
alexandre vient d'un d'un trait de plume
anéantir annulés et est complètement
détruire le secret médical
deuxièmement je pensais que les peler
des praticiens qui ne peuvent pas
soigner aujourd'hui avait un rapport
direct de confiance avec leurs patients
quand vous avez un médecin surtout que
maintenant vous avez un médecin référent
moi j'ai un médecin référent comme tous
les français c'est pas un ami mais c'est
il connaît mon intimité
iq
née ma vie il connaît mes pathologies y
coller mes habitudes et ça m'appartient
et jusque sur l'excellent mieux placé ça
m'appartient et j'ai pas envie d'être
je n'ai pas envie stéphanie de mort ou
d'être dans un fichier dans les médecins
diront qu'ils le qu'il le détruiront
rien le le père mais aujourd'hui rien ne
permet de l'affirmer
en plus on fait intervenir des du privé
avec l'assurance maladie avec les
pharmacies etc
ça sera un autre débat des officines qui
font office justement de récupération de
toutes ces données on ne sait pas ce que
deviennent ces données et moi ce que je
vois c'est que toute liberté perdu est
perdu et je fais confiance à mon médecin
de famille je fais confiance aux
rapports presque intime que j'ai avec
lui pour savoir ce que je dois faire ou
ne pas faire
et j'ai encore le droit d'avoir mon
libre arbitre et que les tous les
français que mon voisin que mon
pharmacien que mon épicier ou que mon
patron si j'en avais un ne soit pas au
courant de mon intimité demande dossier
médical ça c'est la base de toute
société démocratique et c'est la base de
toute société civilisée et évoluer et je
suis scandalisée oui que la cnil est
permis cette infamie alors alex et une
heure mais c'est un propos gentiment
complotistes il n'a jamais été question
de donner ton cancérologique je
l'attendais a jamais été
les jeunes liste je peux vous dire j'ai
cancérologique à lévis y est on est bien
de monsieur alexandre ya un petit c'est
vous que le laisser finir mais sinon non
non non non non l'eugénisme génisses je
peux pas l'aider à développer son idée
un beau nom mais c'est à nous gêne au
repos complet fiche que de dire je me
dis qu'à la fin déjà oui c'est un propos
oui c'est un propos complotistes il est
hors de question que ton dépité jean de
celle-ci calle persson l'argent posé ça
c'est être en mairie zone east a donc là
tu avants néo libérale dur du dossier
médical
arrêté il n'y aura que tommy êtes dans
vos délires donc il n'y aura pas de
rupture du secret médical
aucun acteur c'est vous devenez savez
bien démentant pas là il faut arrêter
prétendent que l'épicier de bas
historique son dossier médical parce que
ça c'est un mensonge complotistes voilà
c'est un mensonge complot tiff
ce n'est pas vrai pour les innovateurs
2010 la liste de la quotidien dirigé par
manier ce genre de facilités stupide
merci je n'ai pas complotistes en france
il y à douala
nous sommes le pays des droits nous
avons un conseil constitutionnel un
terroir la société transgène manistes
dont vous rêvez
c'est un mensonge monsieur alexandre tu
mens était dans le déni merci à tous les
morts et statut a menti tu amendement
monsieur alexandre tu as mangé tous
milieux tranquille avec ce débat on va
on va rester sur cette part est de
mentir sans arrêter de mentir
merci en tout cas boullier maisto
laurent alexandre et pierre schwab s'est
dit on va pas voilà merci d'avoir
accepté ce décryptage qui est devenu un
vrai face à face à heureusement que nous
avions observée en été liée au milieu
pour voilà pour pour ramener un petit
peu de paix sur ce plateau dont je
taquine en tout cas merci d'avoir
accepté de ce débat même si vous n'étiez
pas d'accord dans quel